if Donald Trump is indicted and you
become president
will you pardon him
well I
I have to tell you the truth
I can't completely answer that until I
know what he was charged with and
convicted of
okay so but but I'm not going to dodge
the answer okay
but I will tell you as a prosecutor
if I believe someone has gotten a full
and fair trial in front of a jury of
their peers
and especially someone in public life
who committed those crimes
when they held a public trust I can't
imagine pardoning them okay so I'm
hearing that as almost certainly not not
a perfect answer but a thousand times
better than the answer given by Ron
DeSantis